all right this is what you came here for
it's not trashy when it's a tiny copper
shot glass it's pin trustee pin trashy
pin trash it's trashy pendrick no my
name is very cell baby no no you know
your life is different now welcome to
this YouTube channel okay valentine's
Day is upon us
and you might be getting tail oh I hate
I hate I hate I hate that I actually
said that there's a possibility that you
could be [ __ ] someone so you want to
look your best and hey lose when we
think about getting ourselves ready for
a hot date what kind of makeup do we
think about makeup from 7-eleven now I'm
very late to the Sofia negara train I'm
so late that I'm I'm like still in my
uber trying to catch up with the train
that left on time Sofia used to work at
BuzzFeed she has her own channel now and
she's amazing and I'm obsessed with it
and I saw a video that she made months
ago where she talked about how 7-eleven
released their own line of makeup and
she tested it for a whole day and I
thought that was really cool so one I
thought I'm gonna go to 7-eleven because
I have to see if this exists also I want
that blueberry coffee that they make I'm
trash I'm a garbage human turns out it
does exist my treasures I thought this
is the perfect opportunity to try to
make a very romantic Valentine's Day
date look using only 7-eleven makeup and
on top of that obviously one of the main
reasons that you end up at 7-eleven is
because you're drunk I thought that I
would just support the authenticity
first things first you have to know that
I got as many products as my local
7-eleven offered because leave it or not
it was picked over they didn't offer a
lot of variations of colors and things
like that but there are some things that
were sold out and I have my receipt here
so I can tell you exactly how much this
whole look will cost I feel
there listen I don't know why oh because
everything you do is a little bit wrong
this is my face oh wow I want that I
guess Danny anyway how do you handle
like this the packaging kinda nice
honestly I really wanted it to be like
tiny trash bags I almost passed it by in
the aisle because it was nicer than all
of the flaming hot cheetos that were
surrounding it and it's called simply me
beauty which I guess is in line with
7-eleven when I drunkenly storm into a
7-eleven and need certain salt based
products I'm thinking of simply me and
how beautiful I am so they don't sell
foundation they only have BB cream and
light medium dark but there was no light
color for my skin there was only medium
and dark so I bought the medium and
we'll see so let's try this this is
exactly how I opened a bag of chips this
is two fluid ounces I don't know you
care about that so you could take this
on a plane they sell a beauty blender
they call it a blender sponge oh also
can you see the dust just oh that's dust
this blender was sitting around as long
as those taquitos where I'll take it
that's fine it's only on the outside
that's what I've said about so many
foods I've tried to eat drunk
this is 499 and it's off the table oh my
god I'm using my foot and I don't care
because I just took a shower this is
also $4.99 let's try it
wow that's that's not the right color
for my face we are going to make it work
this is wildly incorrect well I just put
on a self-tanner when I was in the
shower so maybe if we blend it enough
it'll work itself out this color is a
lot like the heartburn that you get from
the hot dog you buy at 7-eleven it's
harsh eyelids oh boy I think I'm crazy
because I think that that might be okay
this seems kind of okay right now and
this light is obviously helping it out a
lot I'm under one more coat and just see
what happens I will say that this sponge
is a friend that you scorned that isn't
mentally mature enough to move on it is
unforgiving that was a long walk maybe
this is the right color for me because I
put on self-tanner on the rest of my
body but this is a wildly different
other than my face started out with okay
I look much more leathery than I did
before but honestly it matches the rest
of my skin next yeah just four okay I'm
Steeler they have high def concealer I
highly doubt that this is high def the
same with the BB cream it came in light
medium and dark how that's nice there's
also $4.99 let's do it whoa Cupid's bow
anything call this the Cupid's bow wait
I don't want to get deep into the idea
of like how Valentine's Day is [ __ ]
insane but let's talk about it for one
second to Lee Hallmark holiday where
they tell you a baby who has no
experience in the world has never
experienced love basically an orphan is
projecting its own ideas of love on to
other people shoot you with an arrow
I'm very nonviolent so that's already
like come on and the arrow is supposed
to hypnotize you to fall in love with
someone else so basically an orphan baby
violently drugs you to fall in love with
someone else that they've also violently
dropped why is no one looking into this
orphan baby
I'm gonna blend this and now I feel like
I'm doing some really cute beef jerky
cosplay right now don't think of the
under eye stuff did anything thanks very
greasy which hey 7-eleven on brand face
fully covered ah the one thing I did not
buy dang it translucent powder they did
actually have translucent powder and I
did not buy it because I was like I
don't need a door but now seeing my face
like this I should have bought it let's
move on temper arrows let's do it this
is their eyebrow kit this is light brown
powder and wax Wow have I told you that
this is not a sponsored video because
it's definitely not definitely wish it
was Cheers
okay this is not a joke but I'm getting
there and what who's the who's who's
who's the Nintendo boss at the end of
your computer history check in browser
like Bowser thank you for your wonderful
packaging just literally like I'm
opening a hard-boiled egg sorry the
recording stop because I just been it's
been 30 minutes so this is the eyebrows
one side is like a wax creamy thing and
one side is a powder this seems like
it's working I mean this ring light is
really giving way too much credit
because I feel like I've retired in
poker time for the last 10 years and
then I've only slept with french fries
on my face this I'd actually be the
right color for my eyebrows okay I can't
tell if I'm drunk or I like this product
this worked great and then this is also
$4.99 who cares no offense to me but I
think I did a great job let's work on
the eyes eyes are the windows to the
soul and in my case the windows are
super dirty I don't clean my windows
ever who does 7-elevens makeup lion has
a couple different versions of little
eyeshadow palettes and I opted for the
heavy metal also I got an eyeshadow
brush right let's spend 12 hours opening
this guy oh this looks like him like a
smoggy sunrise and a very polluted city
you that's how I feel about my eyelids
let's do it I'm gonna go full out and go
in smokey eye oh pollution eyeball need
it oh ok first thing a lot of beauty
gurus do is they take white and they put
it under their brow bone and in this
tear duct so they look wide-awake
wow my brow bones I've never looked more
awake oh wow look at that
welcome back ready here we go gray you
know this Wow okay I'm gonna put bread
this brown I'm gonna swipe it like a MX
card
yep we're going for it I'm going to make
this gray I have ideas take some more of
this hopper e brown color and put it
underneath my eyes that's not a pleasant
face I'm gonna use this navy blue now
put it in the cinched part of your
eyelid the weird part that seems
dehydrated from the rest of your eyelid
you know what's the weirdest thing about
eyeshadow
is that you're trying to accentuate all
these sunken bits in your face here's a
bone but like if we tried to accentuate
like what else accentuate these bones
tell me how beautiful this starts like
wow wow wow that's I mean that's
beautiful okay that commercial break
brought to you by vodka to be fair this
eyeshadow is not bad it's bad there but
not bad here so apparently they did
offer like liquid eyeliner or any kind
of eyeliner but it was sold out at my
local 7-eleven who which I want to say
who bought that before that I want to
move on to cheeks what do you call the
the bronze area that's supposed to be
bronze hollows cheeks nooks and crannies
the nooks the nooks and the crannies I
bought these two blush palettes that
they offered one is called rosy and one
is called coral I bought both of them
it's just what they had now I just feel
gluttonous consumerism was this a good
idea self realized that they didn't have
bronzer and this coral blush said to
have this color that could pass as a
bronzer wow its own brush I literally
bought a blush brush I am delighted I
feel like I just saw close-up magic like
this should be called like Cheetos and
heartburn let's sink in our cheekbones
ready oh yeah we're doing a real
jaundice vibe Oh
let's use the blush brush oh yeah I mean
taste the rainbow Wow dang it I forgot
to keep reading you how much everything
cost I don't know like I said they
offered many options that were not
available one was mascara the one thing
that was available were false eyelashes
I think you look like melting raisins
yeah a lot of bad choices made to me I'm
terrible at putting on false eyelashes
so the best time to do it is now happy
Valentine's Day let's put this glue near
my eyeballs right in my eyelashes
we're - do you see this they've been on
my fishing hand this entire time oh boy
oh boy let's put it run don't even think
right okay look look at these eyes look
at these eyes okay what's left just the
mouth they had a bunch of different lip
products that was the one thing that was
in stock I chose one coke Wafaa creme
lip gloss - beautiful package yeah
started off with not my lip Wow
who is she last thing that I forgot that
I purchased this highlighter combo I
never use highlighter what color is the
one for the one wow it looks really
beautiful wow we did it I mean we should
celebrate with a you know cheers we did
it though there have it there is my
7-eleven romantic date look there's some
products that I didn't use this is all
under $50 you could also go on your date
with no makeup and spend $50 on food and
drink entirely up to you I mean parties
and I I hunt good this looks
thank you guys for watching this video
and liked it give it a thumbs up and do
not forget to subscribe to this channel
I have enough spilt half of it on my
table
dang it and there's no way out of this
corner other than to crawl under the
desk
BRB okay no oh I just scraped my wall
this is not enough paper towel
reset reset